The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
Welcome back.
Since we ended abruptly,
I want to start
with a recap of last time.
And then we've got a lot
of new ground to cover.
So remember last
time, we considered
the system q double dot equals
u, which is of a general form,
just a linear feedback system,
which is state space form
looks like this, where it
happens that a and b are
particularly simple.
And we looked at designing--
let's not say
designing controller--
we looked at reshaping
the phase space
a couple of different ways.
The first way, which is the
sort of 6.302 way, maybe,
would be designing sort
of by pole placement,
by designing feedback gains
possibly by hand, possibly
by a root locus analysis.
So we looked at manually
designing some linear feedback
law, u equals negative Kx.
And we did things like plotting
the phase portrait, which
gave us for q, q dot
a phase portrait that
looked like this, where this has
an eigenvalue of negative 3.75
approximately, and this one had
an eigenvalue of negative 0.25.
This was all for K equals 1, 4.
OK.
And we ended up seeing that
just from that quick analysis
we could see phase portraits
which looked like this.
They come across the
origin, and then they'd
hook in towards the goal.
And similarly here.
This one's so much faster
that it would go like this.
Then we looked at
an optimal control
way of solving the same thing.
We looked at doing a minimum
time optimal control approach,
not specifically so that
we could get there faster,
even though "minimum time"
is in the name, because here
remember, we could get
there arbitrarily fast
by just cranking K as high
as we wanted, but actually
for trying to do something
a little bit smarter, which
is get there in minimum time
when I have an extra constraint
that u was bounded, in the
case we looked at yesterday
was bounded by negative 1, 1.
And in that case when
u was bounded, now
the minimum time problem
becomes nontrivial.
It's not just crank
the gains to infinity.
And we had to use some
better thinking about it.
And the result was a phase
portrait which actually, I
don't know if you
left realizing,
it didn't look that
different in some ways.
Remember, we had these
switching surfaces defined here.
And above this, we'd execute one
policy, one bang-bang solution.
And then below it we'd
execute another one.
And the resulting system
trajectories-- remember,
this one hooked down across the
origin and went into the goal
like that.
This one really did exactly
the same thing, right?
They would start over here.
They'd hook down here with--
this time they'd explicitly
hit that switching surface
and then ride that
into the goal.
So it's a little bit of a
sharper result, possibly,
than the other one.
And that final surface was a
curve instead of this line.
And for that, we got to
have good performance
with bounded torques.
Now, we also did the
first of two ways
that we're going to use
to sort of analytically
investigate optimality.
AUDIENCE: Can I interrupt you?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Anytime, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was there a good
reason we just-- basically said
we want to do linear
feedback there?
Could we have done
like x1 times x2?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good, yeah.
Because-- well, there's
a lot of good reasons.
So it's because then the closed
loop dynamics are linear,
and we can analyze them
in every way, including
making these plots in
ways that I couldn't have
done if this was nonlinear.
Another answer would be that
this is what 90% of the world
would have done, if
that's satisfying at all.
I think that's the
dominant way of sort
of thinking about these things.
x1 times x2 is comparably
much harder to reason about,
actually.
AUDIENCE: I totally get that.
But is there like a system
that the optimal control that
lies in the space that
you have to take into
account these different
approximations.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So this is an example of
a nonlinear controller.
It happens that the
actual control action
is either 1 or negative 1.
But the decision plane
is very nonlinear.
So that's absolutely a
nonlinear controller.
It came out of linear--
out of optimal control
on a linear system.
But the result is a
nonlinear controller.
OK.
Now, certain classes of
nonlinear controllers
are going to pop out and
be easier to think about
than the broad class.
But we're going to see lots of
instances as quickly as we can.
OK.
So we did-- we actually got that
curve by thinking just about--
just using our intuition to
reason about bang-bang control.
At the end, I
started to show you
that the same thing comes out of
what I call solution technique
1 here.
I wouldn't call it that
outside of the room.
That's just me being
clear here, which
was based on Pontryagin's
minimum principle.
Which in this case, is
nothing more than just--
let's write it
down, exactly what
we mean by this cost function.
We have some-- let me be
a little bit more loose.
We have J, some cost
function we want to optimize,
which is a finite
time integral of 1 dt.
That sounds ridiculous, but
we're just optimizing time.
But we want to optimize that
subject to the constraints
that x dot equals f of
x u, which in this case
is our linear system;
and the constraint that u
was negative 1 in that regime;
and the constraint that at time
t, x t had better
be at the origin.
Given those
constraints, we can say
let's minimize T. We're going
to minimize that J, sorry.
I already got the
t in there, so.
Minimize with respect to
the trajectory in x, u,
that cost function.
I use this overbar to
denote the entire time
history of a variable like x
t1 to t final, or something
like this-- time t0 to t final.
OK.
That's how we set
up the problem.
It's just optimizing
some function
but subject to a
handful of constraints.
Pontryagin's minimum
principle is nothing more
than putting Lagrange
multipliers to work
to turn that
constrained optimization
into unconstrained optimization.
And for this problem, we can
build our augmented system
I'll call J prime here,
which just is the same thing
but taking in the constraints.
So first of all, we've got a
constraint on x T equaling 0.
So I can put that in as
a Lagrange multiplier,
let's say lambda times something
that better equal 0, which
in this case was
just x t And then
plus 0 to t1 plus the
constraint on the dynamics,
which I'll call it a different
Lagrange multiplier p,
times f of x, u minus x
dot, this whole thing dt.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
impose the constraint
that u is [INAUDIBLE]?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
Good question.
So it turns out what
we're going to look at--
we want to verify that
this thing is optimal.
So you might want to put that
constraint right in here.
But it actually
is more natural--
here, let me finish
my statement here.
The way we're going to verify
optimality of this policy
is by verifying that we're at
a local minimum in J prime.
I want to say that if I
change x, If I change u,
if I change p in any admissible
way, then J is going to change.
Small changes in here is
not going to change this.
I'm at a local
minima in J prime.
That's the minimum
principle idea, right?
I just want my-- if I'm
at a minimum of function,
the gradient is 0.
In the Lagrange
multiplier, the minimum
of this augmented function,
the gradient had to be 0.
So if I change any of
these, I want that to be--
that change to be 0.
So it turns out that
the more natural way
to look at this
bound in u is by not
changing-- not allowing u to
change outside of that regime.
This is actually
fairly procedural.
So you end up
doing this calculus
of variations on J prime.
But I actually-- I made
a call earlier today.
I think it's going to-- if I do
it right now in the beginning
in class, I'm going
to lose you to--
I mean, I'm going to
bore you and lose you.
But it's in the
notes, and it's clean.
So I'm going to
leave that hanging
and let you look
at it in the notes
without typos that I might
put up on the board, OK?
Because I want to move on
to the dynamic programming
view of the world, sort of
the other possible solution
technique.
OK.
So today, we're going to do--
you can think of it as just
solution technique 2 here.
And it's based on
dynamic programming.
Now, the computer
scientists in the audience
say, I know dynamic programming.
It's how I find the shortest
path between point A and point
B without reusing memory,
and things like that.
And you're exactly right.
That's exactly what it is.
It happens that the
dynamic programming
has a slightly bigger
footprint in the world.
There's a continuous form
of dynamic programming.
OK.
So a graph search is
a very discrete form
of dynamic programming.
So I'm going to
start with sort of--
I'm actually going to work from
the graph search sort of view
of the world, but to make
the continuous form that
works for these continuous
dynamical systems.
And we're going to use this to
investigate a different cost
function, which is just this--
still subject to the
dynamics, which in this case
was the linear dynamics.
OK.
So before we worry
about solving it,
let's take a minute to decide
if it's a reasonable cost
function.
It's different in
a couple of ways.
First of all, there's
no hard limit on u.
But I do penalize for
u being away from 0.
So it's sort of a softer
penalty on u, not a hard limit.
And then these terms
are penalizing it
from being-- the system from
being away from the origin.
And instead of going
for some finite time
and minimizing time, I'm going
to go for an infinite horizon.
So the only way to drive this
thing, the only way, actually,
for J to be a finite cost
over this infinite integral,
is if q and q dot get to
0, and you do u of 0 at 0.
Otherwise, this thing's
going to blow up.
It's going to be an
infinite integral.
So the solution
had better result
in us getting to the
origin, it turns out.
But I'm not trying to
explicitly minimize the time.
I'm just penalizing
it for being away,
and I'm penalizing
it for taking action.
Now, what's the name of
this type of control?
Who knows is?
I think-- yeah, LQR, right?
So this is a Linear
Quadratic Regulator.
OK.
It's a staple of--
it's sort of the best, most used
result from optimal control.
Everybody opens up
Matlab and calls lqr.
But you're going
to understand it.
Good.
But to do LQR, to understand
how that derivation works,
we've got to do-- we're going to
go through dynamic programming.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't we use
the same cost function
there as well?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome.
OK.
So why don't I put that cost
function down and just do
Pontryagin's minimum principal?
There's only one sort
of subtle reason,
which is that that's an
infinite horizon cost.
So I was going to
say this at the end,
but let's have this
discussion now.
So this is an infinite horizon.
Pontryagin's is used to
verify the optimality
of some finite integral.
So let's compare-- well,
I know you know value--
the dynamic programming.
So maybe let me say what
dynamic programming is,
and then I'll contrast them.
Yeah.
But the people sort of--
I just want to
understand what happened.
We got two different
cost functions,
two different solution
techniques for now.
And we're going to
address in a few minutes
why I did different
solution techniques
for the different
cost functions.
But I hope they both seem
like sort of reasonable cost
functions if I want to get
my system to the origin.
Different-- we're going to
look at what the result is,
the different results.
And actually, something
I want to leave you with
is that you can, in fact, do
lots of different combinations
of these things.
You could do quadratic costs and
try to have some minimum time.
There's lots and lots of ways to
formulate these cost functions.
These are two sort
of examples, but you
can do minimum time LQR,
you can do all these things.
OK.
But with the way
we're going to drive
the LQR controller
is by thinking
about dynamic programming.
And to do that, let me start
with the discrete world,
where people-- where
it makes sense.
So let's imagine I have
a discrete time system.
So x of n plus 1
is f of x n u n.
And I have some cost function.
Now remember, in the
Pontryagin minimum principle,
which shows that there's
a sort of a general form
that a lot of these
cost functions
take in the discrete form,
it's h of x at capital
N plus a sum instead
of an integral of n
equals 0 to N minus
1 g of x n u n.
OK.
Now, again, I said this sort of
additive form of cost functions
is pretty common.
And you're going to see right
now one of the reasons why.
The great thing about
having these costs that
accumulate additively
over the trajectory
is that I can make a recursive
form of this equation.
So in particular, if I--
so I should call
this, really, what
I've been calling J, that's
really the J of being at x 0
at time 0.
And I can compute J of
being at x 0 at time 0
and incurring the rest
of the cost recursively
by looking at what it would
be like to be at some state
x at time N--
and that in this case
is just h of x of n--
and then thinking about
what it would be like at--
to be at some J of x N minus 1--
and that's going to be g of
x n minus 1 u of n minus 1
plus h of x n.
Let me be even more careful.
And I'm going to
say, let's evaluate
the cost of running
a particular policy,
u n is just some pi of J of x n.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, why
is the first x a 0,
and then the rest of
the x's [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
So why did I put x 0 here?
That was intentional.
I'm trying to make x 0 the
variable that fits in here.
Here x is the variable
that fits in here.
But you're right, I could
be a little bit more--
I should be more careful.
So now J, a function of
this variable x at time N
should really just be h of x.
Yeah, good.
So then this is--
I could say it this way.
The other way I could say
it is J x minus 1 equals x.
Maybe that's the best
way to rectify it.
OK.
And when I'm evaluating the
cost of a particular policy,
I'm going to use the
notation J pi here,
say this is the cost I
should expect to receive
given I'm in some state x.
To make it even more
satisfying, let's just
be the same everywhere.
This is x 0, and here
I'll say x 0 equals my x.
If I'm in some state x at
time 0 executing policy pi,
I'm going to incur this cost.
If I'm at some state x at
time N incurring this--
taking this policy,
I'm going to get this.
Here I'm going to get this.
And even when I'm
executing policy pi,
I can even furthermore
say that x n
is f of x n minus 1
pi of x n minus 1.
It's probably impossible
to read in that corner.
OK.
So you can see where
I'm going with it.
It's pretty easy to see
that J pi of x at some N
is just the one-step
cost g of x n u
n plus the cost I expect to see
given that x n plus 1 at time
equals 1.
OK.
So the reason we like these
integral costs or the sum
of costs in the
discrete time case
is because I can do these
recursive computations.
And the same thing
true if I look at--
if I define what
the optimal cost is.
So let's now define J
star to be the cost I
incur if I follow the optimal
policy, which is pi star.
Well, it turns out
the same thing works.
But now, there's
an extra term here.
OK.
So it's easy to see that
the cost of following
a particular policy
is recursive.
It's more surprising
that the cost
to go of the optimal
policy is equally
recursive with a simple
form like this, min over u.
And this actually follows
from something called
the principle of optimality.
Anybody see the principle
of optimality before?
OK.
It says that if I want to be
optimal over some trajectory,
I'd better be optimal over--
from the end of that trajectory.
So if I want to be
optimal for the last--
it's from n minus
2 to the end, then
I'd better be optimal
from n minus 1 to the end.
So it turns out if I act
optimally in one step
by doing this min over
u, and then follow
the policy of acting optimally
for the rest of time, then
that's optimal for the
entire function, OK?
OK.
OK, good.
So we've got a recursive form
of this cost-to-go function
that we exploited with
the additive thing,
the additive form.
And now, the optimal
policy comes straight out.
The best thing to do, if
you're in state x and a time n.
is just the arg min over
u of g x, u plus J star
x, n plus 1 n plus 1 with that
same x, n plus 1 defined by--
So in discrete time,
optimal control is trivial.
If you have an additive cost
function, all you have to do
is figure out what your
cost is at the end,
and then go back one step,
do the thing that acts--
that in one step
minimizes the cost
and gets me to the lowest
possible cost in the future.
And if I just do that
recursively backwards,
I come up with
the optimal policy
that gets me from any x
in n steps to the end.
Does that make sense?
Ask questions.
Do people buy that?
Is that obvious, or does
that need more explanation?
OK.
Ask questions if you have them.
All right.
So we're going to use the
discrete time form again
when we get to the algorithms.
But I'm trying to use
it today to leapfrog
into the continuous time
conditions for optimality.
So what happens if we now do
the same sort of discrete time
thinking, but do it in the limit
where the time between steps
goes to 0?
So let me try to do the
limiting argument to get us back
to continuous time.
OK.
Now we've got our cost function,
again, is h of x at capital T
plus the integral from
0 to T of g x, u dt.
The analogous statement
from this recursion
in the discrete time
is that J x at t
is going to be a
limiting argument as dt
goes to 0 of the min over
u of g x, u dt plus J
x of t plus dt t plus dt.
OK.
This is now-- that's
just a limiting argument
as dt goes to 0 of the
same recursive statement.
I'm going to approximate
J x of t plus dt as--
this is J star let me
not forget my stars--
as J star at x t plus
partial J star partial x
x dot dt plus partial
J star partial t dt.
It's a Taylor
expansion of that term.
OK.
If I insert that back in,
then I have J star x of t
equals the limit as dt
goes to 0 min over u g
x, u dt plus partial
J star partial x--
x dot is just f of
x, u, remember--
dt plus partial J partial t dt.
And I left off that J x
there, because that actually
doesn't depend on u.
So I'm going to put that
outside here, plus J x and t.
Those guys cancel.
And now I've got
a dt everywhere.
So I can actually take that
out, and my limiting argument
goes away.
And what I'm left
with, 0 equals min
over u g of x, u plus
partial J partial x star
plus partial J partial t.
This is a very famous
equation, will be used a lot.
It's called the
Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation.
AUDIENCE: Russ.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes?
Did I miss--
AUDIENCE: x dot in
the middle term there.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Here?
AUDIENCE: Last equation.
That x dot [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, thanks.
Good.
This is f of x, u.
Thank you.
Good, thank you.
That is the
Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation, often
known as the HJB.
So Hamilton and Jacobi
are really old guys.
Bellman's a newer guy.
He was in the '60s or something.
A lot of people say
Hamilton-Bellman-Jacobi.
That doesn't seem
quite right to me.
That's some guy in the
'60s sticking his name
in between Hamilton and Jacobi.
So I try to--
I will probably say HBJ a
couple of times in the class,
but whenever I'm thinking
about it I say HJB, OK?
OK.
So we did a little bit
of work in discrete time.
But the absolute output
of that thinking,
the thing you need
to remember, is
this Hamilton-Jacobi-Bellman
equation, OK?
These turn out to be the
conditions of optimality
for continuous time.
Let's think about what it means.
So do you have yet a picture
of this sort of what J is.
J is a cost-to-go.
It's a function over
the entire landscape.
It tells me if I'm in
some state, how much cost
am I going to incur
with my cost function
as it runs off into time.
In the finite horizon
case, it's just an integral
to the end of time.
In the infinite
horizon case, I've
started this initial condition,
and I run my cost function
forever.
So j is a cost landscape,
a cost-to-go landscape.
This statement here
says that, if I
move a little bit in that
landscape in x, scale
by this x dot, then the
thing I should incur
is that is my
instantaneous cost.
OK.
The way my cost
landscape-- the difference
of being in initial
condition 1 versus being
in initial condition 2,
if they're neighboring,
goes like the cost function.
And there's the cost function--
the cost-to-go function lives
in x, and it lives in time.
OK.
It's one of the most important
equations we'll have--
Hamilton-Bellman-Jacobi
equation.
AUDIENCE: So we can take out the
partial case that [INAUDIBLE]??
Because that one Is independent
of u, the last term.
So if we take that
out, basically,
the difference between the value
to [INAUDIBLE] with respect
to time, in this time and going
to the next time that sort
of seems like a
TD error squared--
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Good.
There's absolutely-- this is
exactly the source of the TD
error and the Bell-- yeah.
It's exactly the
Bellman equation.
So yeah.
So you're right.
Partial J partial t could have
been outside the min over u.
It doesn't actually have u.
But we're going to see
all those connections
as we get into the algorithms.
But for-- this now is a tool
for proving analytically
and driving analytically
some optimal controllers.
We need one more--
we need to say something
stronger about how useful
that tool is.
So there's the
sufficiency theorem
is what gives this
guy teeth, OK?
So I told you that the
Pontryagin's minimum principle
was a necessary
condition for optimality.
It wasn't necessarily
sufficient.
If you show that the system
satisfies the Pontryagin's
minimum principle,
then you're close,
but you actually also have to
say it uniquely solves that,
it's the only solution to
that, solves the Pontryagin's
minimum principle.
So there's extra work needed.
The theorem we're putting
up here is this saying--
is going to say that if
this equation is satisfied,
then that's sufficient
to guarantee
that the policy is optimal.
OK.
So given a policy pi x of t,
and a cost-to go function,
J pi x of t, if pi is
the argument of this,
if pi is the policy which
minimizes that for all x
and all t, and that condition
is met, then we can--
that's sufficient to
give that J pi x of t
equals J pi of x of t and
pi x of t pi star x of t.
OK.
The proof of that I'm
not even going to try.
It's sort of tedious.
It's in Bertsekas, if you like--
Bertsekas' book.
But we're going
to use this a lot.
So if I can find some
combination of J, pi, and pi
that match that condition, then
I've found an optimal policy.
OK.
Let's use this to solve
the problem we want--
the linear quadratic
regulator in its general form.
So they've got a system
x equals Ax plus Bu.
And let's say I have a
cost function J of x 0
is h of x, t--
the same thing I've been
writing all day here--
g of x, u dt, where x 0
equals x, where h in general
takes the form x
transpose Qfx, and g
takes the form x transpose
Qx plus u transpose Ru.
To make things-- to be careful,
we're going to assume that--
we're going to enforce-- we're
choosing the cost function.
We're going to enforce that this
is positive definite, making
sure we don't get any
negative cost here.
And similarly-- actually, it
only has to be semi-definite.
Q transpose equals
Q greater than
or equal to 0 and R
transpose equals R.
That one does have
to be positive.
Definite
OK.
Here's a pretty general
linear dynamical system,
quadratic regulator cost.
To satisfy the
HBJ, we simply have
to have that this condition--
so 0 equals min over u x
transpose Qx plus u transpose
Ru plus partial J partial
x star times Ax plus Bu
plus partial J star partial
t, that had better equal 0.
So I need to find that
cost-to-go function which
makes this thing 0.
It turns out the
solution to these things,
we can just guess a form for J.
Let's guess that J star x of t
is also quadratic,
again with a positive--
it's going to have
to be positive.
It could be-- in that
case, partial J partial
x is 2x transpose S of t.
Partial J partial t is
x transpose s dot t x.
OK.
Let's pop this guy in.
I want to just
crank through here.
So does it make sense at
all, that the J of x, t
would be a quadratic
form like that?
Why is that a reasonable guess?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because the
final time [INAUDIBLE]
match the [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK.
So in the final time,
that's a reasonable guess,
because it started like this.
Yeah.
And it turns out--
I mean, we're actually going
to see it by verification.
But for the linear system,
when I pump the cost backwards
in time, this
quadratic cost, it's
going to have to stay quadratic.
OK.
So I've got 0 equals min over u
x transpose Qx plus u transpose
Ru plus 2x transpose S of t--
bless you-- times Ax plus
Bu plus x transpose S t x.
I need that whole
thing to work out
to be 0 for the minimizing u.
So let's figure out what
the minimizing u is now.
Is it OK if I just
sort of shorthand?
I'll say the gradient
of that whole thing
in square brackets with respect
to u here is going to be,
what, 2Ru--
or u transpose R, I guess?
We're going to try to be
careful that this whole thing is
a scalar.
We're always talking
about scalar costs.
So I've got vectors and
matrices going around,
but the whole thing has to
collapse to be a scalar.
The gradient of a scalar
with respect to a vector,
I want it to always be a vector.
The gradient of a vector
with respect to a vector
is going to be a matrix.
So try to be careful
about making--
that gradient better be a
vector plus what's left here?
2x transpose S that
guy there, right?
But I have to take
the transpose of that.
So it's 2B transpose S of t.
The S t transpose is not x--
I screwed up, sorry.
It's still x transpose.
I'm trying to-- x transpose S
t B. That thing has to equal 0.
And that's where I
get my transpose back.
So u star, the u that makes this
gradient 0, is going to be--
those 2's cancel.
It's going to be negative
R inverse B transpose
S transpose x.
Which is important to
realize that was actually--
it's equivalent to writing
negative 1/2 R inverse
B transpose partial J
partial x transpose.
OK.
So what does this mean?
So I've got some
quadratic approximation
of my value function.
It's 0 at the origin
always and forever.
If I'm at the origin, I'm
going to stay at the origin,
my cost-to-go is 0.
The exact shape of the quadratic
bowl changes over time.
The best thing to
do is to go down
to negative of the
partial J partial x
is trying to go down
the cost-to-go function.
I want to go down the cost-to-go
function as fast as I can.
But I'm going to wait--
I'm going to change,
possibly, the exact direction.
Rather than going straight down
the cost-to-go function in x,
I might orient
myself a little bit
depending on the
weightings I put
on-- the cost I put on
the different u's. So I'm
going to rotate that
vector a little bit.
This is what I can do, and this
is the weighting I've done.
So the best thing to do is to go
down your cost-to-go function,
get to the point where
my cost-to-go is going
to be as small as
possible, filtered
by the direction
I can actually go
and twisted by the way
I penalize actions.
OK.
And it's sort of
amazing, I think,
that the whole thing works out
to be just some linear feedback
law negative Kx--
yet another reason
[INAUDIBLE] to use that form.
OK.
Sorry, I should be
a little careful.
This is-- it depends on time.
So it's K of t x.
Why should it depend on time?
This is a-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: We switch.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Because
we switch what?
AUDIENCE: The actuation.
RUSS TEDRAKE: There's no hard
switch in the actuation here.
This is saying, I'm
going to smoothly go down
a value function.
This one isn't the
bang-bang controller.
This turns out to
be a smooth descent
of some cost-to-go function.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The S t equals
partial [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: I mean, S of t
is time [INAUDIBLE] itself.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
so it [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: So
intuitively, why should I
take a different linear
control action if I'm at a time
1 versus time 2?
AUDIENCE: Because
you're time dependent.
So if you're very close
to the final time,
you want to [INAUDIBLE]
lots of control,
because you don't have
that much time [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: Awesome, yeah.
This is a quirk of having a
finite horizon cost function.
In the infinite horizon
case, it turns out
you're going to just get
a u equals negative Kx,
where K is a variant of time.
But in the time--
finite horizon problem,
there's this quirk,
which is the time
ends at some point,
and I have to deal with it.
If the bank closes at 5:00,
if I'm here and it's 4:50,
and the bank closes at
5:00, I'm going to--
I'd better get over there
faster than if it was 4:30
and the bank closes at 5:00.
In my mind, actually, there's
a lot of problems that are--
bank closing is a
weird one, but there
are a lot of problems that
are naturally formulated
as finite horizon problems.
Things-- maybe a pick-and-place.
The minimum time problem was a
finite horizon, pick-and-place.
There are a lot of problems
which are naturally
formulated as infinite horizon.
I just want to walk as
well as I possibly can
for a very long time.
I don't need to get to some
place at a certain time.
OK.
But in many ways, the
finite horizon time ones
are the weird ones,
because you always
have to worry about the
end of time approaching.
OK.
AUDIENCE: How do we get S t?
RUSS TEDRAKE: How do we get S t?
OK.
Well, it's the thing that
makes this equation 0.
So what is that thing?
I figured out what
the minimizing u is.
I can insert that back in.
So I get now 0 equals
Q plus x transpose--
I'm going to insert u in--
K-- or I'll do the
whole thing, actually--
S of t B R inverse
times R times R inverse.
So I'm going to go ahead
and cancel those out.
B transpose S of t x.
And the negative signs,
because there's two u's there.
The negative sign didn't get me.
And then plus 2x
transpose S of t Ax plus--
so minus B R inverse B transpose
S of t x plus x transpose S dot
of x.
It turns out that
this term here should
be the same as that term
there, modulo of factor 2.
If you look, it's S, B, R
inverse, B transpose, S.
So this one actually, I can
just turn that into a minus.
OK.
And it turns out that everything
has this x transpose matrix x
form.
So I can actually--
in order for this thing
to be true for all x,
it must be that the matrix
inside had better be 0.
So it turns out to be 0
equals Q minus S t B R
inverse B transpose S t
plus 2 S t A plus S dot t
had better be equal to 0.
OK.
Now, I made some
assumptions to get here.
Know what assumptions I made?
The big one is that I guessed
that form of the value
function.
And one of the things
I guessed about it
was that it was symmetric.
So let's see if we're
looking symmetric.
So Q, we already
said, was symmetric.
That's all good.
That guy's nice and symmetric.
So this is the one we
have to worry about.
Is that guy symmetric?
It's actually not
symmetric like that.
But I can equivalently write it
as S t A plus A transpose S t,
since S is symmetric.
And that guy is symmetric.
I said a very strange thing.
I just said that
the matrices are--
this one is not symmetric,
I can write the same thing
as-- it's this.
So what I mean to say is that
these are equivalent for all x.
Because this has
got to equal this.
OK.
So, good.
So this equation,
which I'm going
to write one more
time since it's
an equation that has
a name associated
with someone famous--
deserves a box
around it, I guess.
So this is the Riccati equation.
I'm going to move the
S over to this side.
It's a Riccati equation.
And I also have
that final condition
that you rightly pointed
out, where S of capital T
had better equal Qf.
So direct application of
the Hamilton-Bellman-Jacobi
equation, I was able to derive
this Riccati equation, which
gives me a solution
for the value function.
Because it gives me a
final condition on an S
and then the governing
equation which
integrates the equation
backwards from capital T to 0.
And once I have S,
remember, we said
that the u was just negative R
inverse B transpose S of t x.
So I've got everything.
Once I have S, I
have everything.
OK.
So this is one of the
absolute fundamental results
in optimal control.
It turns out that if you want
to know the infinite horizon
solution to the--
if you look at the solution
as time goes to infinity--
remember, I wrote my cost
function initially was--
the problem we're trying to
solve is an infinite integral.
It turns out that
the infinite solution
is the steady-state
solution of this equation.
So if you integrate this
equation back enough,
it's stable.
It finds a steady
state where S dot is 0.
And that solution
when S dot equals
0, The S which solves this,
that whole thing minus Q,
is the infinite
horizon solution.
OK.
If you open up Matlab, and
you type lqr A, B, Q, R,
then it's going to
output two things.
It outputs K, and it outputs S.
Solving this thing is actually
not trivial.
So how do you solve that for S?
The hard one is it's got
this S in both places.
But this is the
Lyapunov equation again.
It's so famous, it
comes up so pervasively,
that people have really
good tools for solving it,
numerical tools for solving it.
So Matlab's got some
nice routine in there
to solve, to find S.
And when I call lqr
with the dynamics
and the Q, R gives me exactly
the infinite horizon S
and infinite horizon
non-time-variant K.
If you need to do a finite
horizon quadratic regulator,
then you actually need to
integrate these equations
yourself.
OK.
I hate going that long with just
equations and not intuition.
So let me connect it
back to the brick now.
That was the point of doing
everything in the brick world
here.
OK.
So we've got Q
double dot equals u.
We've got now
infinite horizon J x
is infinite horizon g x,
u dt, where I said g x,
u was 1/2 Q squared plus 1/2 Q
dot squared plus 1/2 u squared.
So now that's exactly in
the LQR form 0, 1, 0, 0.
B is 0, 1.
Q is the identity matrix.
And R is 1.
It turns out I
can actually solve
that one algebraically for S.
If you pump all the symbols in--
I won't do it because
there's a lot of symbols--
but in a few lines of algebra,
you can figure out what S has
to be, just because so many
terms drop out with those
0's that actually there's--
There's the three equations
and three unknowns.
And it turns out that S has
to be square root of 2, 1, 1,
square root of 2.
OK.
The u, remember, was negative
R inverse B transpose
B transpose S x, which,
if I punch those in,
gives me 1 square
root of 2 times
x, which gives me closed loop
dynamics of x dot equals Ax
minus BKx is equal
to 0, 1, negative 1,
square root of 2 times x.
OK.
Now I'm going to
plot two things here.
First thing I'm going
to plot is J of x.
J of x is square root of
2, 1, 1, square root of 2.
A little thinking
about that, you'll
see that it comes out to
be an ellipsoid that is--
[INAUDIBLE]---- sort
of shaped like this.
I draw contours
of that function,
of that x transpose S x.
And the cost-to-go is 0 here.
And it's a bowl that comes up
in this sort of elliptic bowl.
All right.
So what is the optimal
policy going to look like,
given that that's my bowl?
We said the best thing to do
is go down the steepest descent
of the bowl.
I want to go down--
wherever I am, I want to
go down as fast as I can.
But I can't do it exactly.
That was actually sort of a--
that's OK.
I mean, I can't do it exactly,
because all I'm allowed to do
is change--
I have one component that I'm
not allowed to change, right?
I have that my Q is going to
go forward independent of u
directly.
So B transpose S x is going
to be give me a projection
of that gradient onto this--
the thing I can
actually control,
which way I can point
my phase portrait
in that given my control.
And then R is going
to scale it again.
And the resulting
closed loop dynamics,
let's see if we can
figure that out.
So if I take the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues that, well,
it turns out I'm not
going to make the plot.
My eigenvalues were square
root of 2 plus or minus i 1
over square root of 2 with v
being 1 over square root of 2.
So the best thing I can
possibly do is to go down that--
if I didn't care about--
if I didn't worry
about penalizing R,
I didn't worry about
my control actuation,
would be to go straight
down that bowl.
But because I'm
scaling things by--
I'm filtering things by wearing
what I can actually control,
and I'm penalizing things
by R, the actual response
is a complex response
which goes down--
goes down this bowl
and oscillates its way
into the origin.
OK, good.
It was a little painful.
But that is a set
of tools that we're
going to lean on when we're
making all our algorithms.
You've now seen a pretty
representative sampling
of what people can
do analytically
with optimal control.
When you have a linear
dynamical system,
and there's a handful of cost
functions which you can--
either by Pontryagin
or dynamic programming,
the Hamilton-Bellman-Jacobi
sufficiency theorem,
those are really the two big
tools that are out there.
In cases, especially
for linear systems,
you can analytically come up
with optimal control policies
and value functions.
Why did we distinguish the two?
Why did I use one in
one place and the other
in the other place?
Well, it turns out the
Hamilton-Bellman-Jacobi
sufficiency theorem has
in it these partial J
partial x, partial J partial t.
So it's only valid, actually, if
partial J partial x is smooth.
The policy we got
from minimum time
has this hard nonlinearity
in the middle of it.
It turns out that
the value function
that you have in the
minimum time problem
also has a hard
nonlinearity in it.
If I'm here versus
here, it's smooth,
but the gradients
are not smooth.
The gradient is discontinuous.
So on this cusp, partial
J partial x is undefined.
So that's the only
reason why I didn't
lean on the sufficiency
theorem completely.
How did Pontryagin
get around that?
The sufficiency theorem
is talking about--
it's looking at over--
roughly over the
entire state space.
It's looking at variations
in the cost-to-go function
as I move in x and in time.
Pontryagin, if you remember, was
along a particular trajectory.
It was verifying that
a particular trajectory
was locally optimal.
And it turns out in
problems like this
in these bang-bang problems,
along a particular trajectory,
my cost-to-go is smooth.
The cost-to-go in the
minimum time problem
was just time, right?
So the time I get--
the time it takes for
me to go to here to here
is just smoothly decreasing
as I get closer like time.
Along any trajectory,
with these additive costs,
the value function is
going to be smooth.
But along a
non-system trajectory,
some line like this, partial--
if I just look at J, how J
varies over x, it's not smooth.
So Pontryagin is a
weaker statement.
It's a statement about local
stability along a trajectory.
But it's valid in
slightly larger domains,
because it doesn't
rely on value functions
being smoothly differentiable.
Now, for the first-order--
sorry, for the double
integrator, the brick on ice,
we could have just
chosen our K's by hand
and pushed them
higher or smaller.
We could do locus.
We could figure out a
pretty reasonable set
of K's, of feedback gains, to
make it stabilize to the goal.
LQR gives us a different set
of knobs that we could tune.
Now we could more
explicitly say what
our concern is for getting
to the goal by the Q matrix,
versus what our concern is
about using a lot of cost
in the R matrix.
So maybe that's not
very compelling.
Maybe we just did a
lot of work to just
have a slightly
different set of knobs
to turn when I'm designing
my feedback controller.
But what you're
going to see is that,
for much more complicated
systems that are still linear--
or linearizations about
very complicated systems,
LQR is going to give
you an explicit way
to design these linear feedback
controllers in a way that's
optimal.
So we're actually doing
a variation of LQR
now to make an airplane land
on a perch, for instance.
We can-- we're going
to use it to stabilize
the double-inverted pendulum,
the Acrobot, around the top.
So it's going to be a
generally more useful tool.
Down at the brick,
double integrator level,
you can think it's almost
just a different set of ways
to do your locus.
OK.
You have now, through
two sort of dry lectures
relative to the
rest of the class,
learned two ways to do
analytical optimal control.
One is by means of
Pontryagin's minimum principle,
one is by means of
dynamic programming, which
is through the HJB
sufficiency theorem.
And you've seen
some representatives
of what people can do with those
analytical optimal control.
And it got us far enough to
make a brick go to the origin.
Right.
And it'll do a few
more things, but.
OK, so that's about as far
as we get with analytics.
We're going to use this in
places to start algorithms up.
But if we want to, for instance,
solve the minimum time problem
or the quadratic
regulator problem,
for the nonlinear
dynamics of the pendulum,
if I take my x dot
equals Ax plus Bu away
and give it the mgL sine
theta, then most of these tools
break down.
Next Tuesday happens to be
a holiday, virtual Monday.
So we won't do it
on next Tuesday.
But next Thursday, I'm
going to show you algorithms
that are based on these.
This is the important foundation
that are going to solve
algorithmically the same optimal
control problems that we're--
more optimal control problems
that we can solve analytically.
And then the-- we'll
go on from there
to more and more
complicated systems.